This happened on BBC.com.
Google is trying
to make our emoji more diverse.
No, they aren't adding
a diarrhea emoji.
Although, they should.
Although, what would it be?
Would it be just, like,
one splat with eyes?
Would it be
with the eyes'd be like, "Mah?"
Would it, like, stretch across
an entire line of text?
Would there be
an explosion point?
Would there be a splatter point?
What would it be?!
Anyway, they want to make new
emoji for professional women,
and it's about goddamn time
because...
(applause and cheering)
-Take it easy.
-The only ones
currently available
feature women
in stereotypical roles,
like wife
and salsa dancer stomping a bug.
-(laughter) -So Google engineers
designed 13 emoji
of professional women and
presented them for approval
to the governing body of emoji,
the Unicode Consortium,
which sounds a lot like the name
of a store set
in the world of Harry Potter.
-(laughter)
-Here's some they're proposing.
Uh, sweet, awesome.
Health care professionals.
That's a no-brainer.
What else we got?
Yes, absolutely.
Scientist. Duh.
-Of course, absolutely.
-Mm-hmm.
Women have made tons of amazing
contributions to science.
This is absolutely deserved.
What else?
-Oh, a welder. All right.
-(laughter)
Sure. Why not?
-Listen, hey, come on.
-(applause and cheering)
Yup.
But, uh, while I do believe
that there are absolutely
women welders,
I don't know when you would ever
use this emoji.
-(laughter)
-I can't...
quite come up with a
circumstance
where a lady welder emoji
would be necessary.
-We might be able to help you
with that. -(laughter)
HARDWICK:
I wonder if there were only
some comedians here
who might be able to send a text
that would require
a female welding emoji.
Uh, Randy Sklar.
Hey, guys. Just putting
the finishing touches
on that glass ceiling
those guys had me build.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Hey! Nice. Very good.
-(applause and cheering)
-Yup. Yup. Yup.
Jason Sklar.
Uh, Mom and Dad, I'm a lesbian,
a flaming lesbian.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Jesus Christ.
(applause and cheering)
Jon Dore.
Um, it's, uh,
Happy Father's Day.
I, uh, ran out of money,
but I thought
you could jerk off to this.
(laughter and groaning)
-Oh, Jesus Christ. Oh, my God.
-(applause and cheering)
No reason why we can't jerk off
to women in the workplace.
Yeah.
It's my fault!
It's all my fault!